okay Alfredo Alfredo where'd you grow up
for you from Rizzoli
um I grew up here in La Puente
California okay suburb of La yes and
tell me about your family had both your
parents growing up uh yes they were old
fashioned Mexican family my dad took off
a really early tonight and my childhood
I grew up with three brothers and one
sister and pretty much you know I did
the whole thing I went to I want to you
know normal high school public school I
graduated you know there was a know a
bit of alcoholism in my family but
nothing major you know it was just it
was just whatever you know but uh that's
me I mean me me yeah yeah that's good
so from when you left your parents house
and went on your own where'd you go from
there
you're married do you have kids yeah um
yes I have I have one girl um she's
already grown though but yeah I uh I
have to grad after I graduated and I
moved out of the house I got married
about two years later I got married to
my high school sweetheart you're still
married well I'm in the verge of getting
a divorce right now okay she already
filed for divorce so you know messing up
but it's no it's uh it's uh it was
inevitable and now it's not you know
it's not a solvable so you know it is
what it is it's better this way the good
thing is that you know we only have one
child which she's already grown so I'll
be all right where do you work I work at
an animal shelter in Pasadena okay
and so you let you like to come down to
skid row and pick up some of the ladies
sometimes yeah um pride I probably do it
every other day really yeah that's a lot
and you'll come down during the day or
after work or well right now I'm not
working I got heard at work so I got all
this free time and yeah I usually
usually a comma
I'll come out at night yeah but
sometimes I come out in the day and you
have certain girls that you I have
certain girls yeah and you'll take them
in your car hotel yeah well usually uh
you know we'll do the thing in the car
well I'll Drive out to one of these
abandoned streets down here on Skid Row
and uh you know we do the thing yeah dad
they get paid and I'm happy I'll go home
yeah yeah if you ever had any
shenanigans go on like the girls tried
to rob you or yeah not try have oh
really yeah okay what kind of a couple
of occasions
uh one time I want this girl we went we
pulled into a gas station she wanted
condoms and so I you know I pulled into
a gas station I don't know what I was
thinking but uh you know I left uh I
left my wallet in between the car seat
and the console and I remembered that I
had some loose change in my pocket so
you know I walk I walked in it was a
7-eleven I bought the condoms when I
came out the girl was gone I saw was my
wallet uh-huh about $600 in there out
yeah so it goes with the Neira didn't it
goes with the territory right and also I
had but um after that it was a little
bit of a learning experience every time
I learned something new you know and and
it's pretty much not to trust the girl
you know what I mean so um but in time I
learned I learned I I I'm
some girls and I I pretty much stayed
with those you know so now it's like
sometimes I call and they tell me to
meet them somewhere around here I pick
them up and you know that's it yes it
develops little bit of trust I well yeah
not on the way but you know yeah it what
with what with what I can you know I
mean right but uh I've never I mean I've
never taken one of them to my house or
or you know I've never you know I've
never given them my real names you know
and stuff like that no I just still want
it to be safe yeah and you use condoms
when you do this yeah I use condoms once
in a while you know I'll go wrong once
in a while and it's because of
situations like you know the toilet the
ones when I pulled into the 7-eleven but
um other than that I mean you know I use
protection as much as I can
yeah I just think there's some diseases
down here that you don't want to get
anywhere close to I really I've been you
know not gone what I've been I've been
pretty safe as far as diseases go you
know as because I I don't know this is
this has become like pretty much an
addiction for me you know I cannot do
this yeah you know I gotta calm how do
you know you know I gotta can I say
you're Batman yeah I gotta come out and
get a [ __ ] you know what I mean I
mean that's it so it's a it's mandatory
you know and so sometimes I have a
little booze on me and you know but uh
it's become rather an expensive habit do
you think it's gonna turn into something
where it would make it hard for you to
have a relationship with a female that's
not doing you're not not gonna have sex
with you in the first minute I think I
think yes I think eventually it will
because
you know I have my wife or you know if I
you know meet another girl or my
girlfriend and stuff I don't know I
can't I can't do the things with her
that I can with you know I yeah
eventually I think that it's gonna get
in the way of my relationship because
either she you know either she'll find
out you know either I'll get arrested
god forbid or something and then you
know I mean then they call or whatever
man
you know she finds out that way I just
don't want to uh you know I just try to
be careful you know as much as I can
yeah but if that I really get in the way
of our normal relationship it can if you
can but it also you can contain it you
know not forever but you can contain it
yeah you know the best you can have you
ever been arrested for this for that no
no thank goodness I haven't I've been
I've been lit up with a spotlight during
the during and you know during a session
and on my back seat but they were cool
about it they just kept going twice a
matter of fact our once in the park and
the Griffith Park but in the one in
Griffith not in Griffith Park Elysian
Park but the one in Elysian Park I was
pulled over we were in out in a in a
no-parking zone and the park rangers
Anna Anna
LAPD cruiser they got behind me they put
the lights and like I said we were you
know we're getting busy in there and so
they gave me a ticket here take a big
big big run see oh no not because
vagrancy right is that is that what it's
called yeah okay so vagrancy and parked
in our public private property that's
what that's what they'll take you before
I never want to put for it yeah do you
ever even think about the fact that
these girls are just doing it for money
so they can buy drugs do I think they're
not they're not doing it because they I
mean you're very handsome and you seem
like a good guy
thank you but it's not because you're
handsome and a good guy it's because you
have money damn right yeah it's for the
money does it
I know that does that thought ever come
into your head it comes it comes it
comes it to my head of course you know I
I mean but I don't feel bad about it you
know I mean it is what it is
that's the rehearsal um you know some
are more expensive than others
what's the most you've paid Oh eighty
hey what's the least you think oh and
you'll have intercourse you'll have blow
job it all depends on you know what my
mood is and what and how much money I
got it could go in a course or or I
could just get some head and that's it
yeah and you have to be drunk to do this
you think no IIIi have been but uh I
don't have to be yeah you know I kind of
like it when I'm not though yeah you
know when I'm sober and stuff so because
when I'm when I'm drunk you know I kind
of it you know how I say that you know
the more I see you know this though the
ones you know the ones that I you know
associate with they're they're pretty
much they're pretty girls you know so
it's like sometimes I get I you know I I
think to myself I am you know where's
this chick then you know who has she
been with how many dudes did she do this
today or you know and all that you know
I mean all that put up plays into and
plays a role in it and it's like I just
forgot about it
you know but like I said that you know
that that's that's their host I can't
knock them for it yeah alright afraid oh
well thank you so much for talking hey
you're welcome well thank you for being
so open and honest all I am no problem
that's that's what it's about
maybe
you